Yann toujours à l'heure
toujours à l'heure, toujours en vie
le temps c'est de l'argent
le retard c'est du plomb, dans la cervelle
"rires"
j'imagine que t'es pas venu jusqu'ici pour me parler métaux précieux ?
qu'est-ce que tu veux ?
une mission, encore une et pour celle-ci j'ai besoin d'une équipe en or, il me faut les meilleurs
les meilleurs ...
j'ai ça
je te présente Bruce Mac Allister, expert en explosifs
Eliot Craig, dit le druide, un génie de l'informatique
Ken Carter un spécialiste des arts-martiaux
et Keven Bufford expert en sport de combats
mais c'est un peu la même chose que celui d'avant...
Harry Dickinson, acrobate accompli
Andrew Bower, extêmement agaçant
extêmement agaçant c'est à dire ?
"marmone" extêmement agaçant c'est à dire ?
ah ok ...
Jackson Purlman notre fondu d'armes à feu
"marmone"
merci
Thomas Fergusson qui tape dans ses mains
j'adore ce mec
Mike Carlton, qu'on n'écoute jamais
nan c'est pas qu'on m'écoute jam...
Stan Patterson qui manipule le temps ... temps ... temps qui manipule le temps, qui manipule le temps, qui manipule le temps et c'est super chiant donc il va arrêter
désolé
Clark Patrick hyper nerveux
Henrique Leblanc expert en mimes
Martin Standford spécialiste des guillemets avec les doigts
oui enfin..." spécialiste"
Alexandro Ramirez tireur à l'arc hors pair
nan parce que Alexandro il est malade, donc c'est moi qui le remplace
Derek Barker expert en camouflage
là pour le coup c'est super parce que vraiment on voit rien quoi
vous parlez de moi ?
ah mais non mais Derek, il a dit Derek tu t'appelles Derek peut-être ?
ah mais je sais pas
oui ben écoute, tu n'écoutes rien
bon on peut enchaîner ?
"marmone" bon on peut enchaîner ?
il est pas mort lui ?
nan c'est parce qu'il est immortel
"marmone" il est immortel
nan il meurt et il revit
ah ok parce que je me demandais pourquoi vous le gardiez parce qu'il est quand même très agaçant quoi
ben c'est pour ça
d'accord
ah pardon c'est parce que tout à l'heure
nan t'inquiète c'est bon
merci
Ammister Dolovan qui voit dans le futur
oui d'ailleurs allez-y mollo parce que sinon je ne vais plus voir grand chose
Franck Hamil feru de pilotage ffff.. Franck a fait pipi, Franck fait pi ... pi
bon
Henrique Leblanc, expert en mimes
nan nan nan putain stop c'est ça ton équipe en or ?
ce sont les meilleurs
oui enfin les "meilleurs" ...
ta gueule toi, moi je me casse
"applaudissements"
nickel, je vous avais prévenu qu'on allait plus voir grand chose
bon je vous laisse une dernière chance on a assez de flics, qu'on en finisse
alors juste qu'on en finisse avec quoi ?